there are about 700 or so leftist
marches over the weekend organized to
protest president Trump's zero tolerance
approach to border jumpers
we have children being housed in cages
crying for their mommies and daddies we
know we are better than this do we want
to be in America that values children
and families I always say the power of
the people shall and will be a lot
stronger than the people in power did
you hear that Donald Trump where's the
love Donald Trump I don't even know who
that is what is that well they were
fulminating about family separations of
course at the border despite the fact
that President Trump ended that policy
two weekends ago do they not read well
of course what all of you smart people
already know because you watch the
Ingraham angle the left isn't really
worried about the kids
it's that cynical well maybe it is but
if they were really worried about kids
they would be at regular rallies in
Chicago and Baltimore we're still an
unacceptably high number of children are
left fatherless or even die themselves
because of gang bangers and fighting
turf wars now what's most upsetting to
these protesters is that despite all
their efforts Trump's approval numbers
keep edging up so their only recourse is
to demonize Trump as a heartless baby
jailer do you know something they always
say kids in cages it like it's like kids
in cages can you hear that all the time
well it's also an opportunity of course
for Democrats to trot out new radical
policy positions now ever since that 28
year old socialist in New York
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez beat Democratic
incumbent of course Joe Crowley Democrat
from leadership number four in the party
the party's old guard has been reeling
now they're straining for relevance and
they're tripping all over themselves to
align with that millennial socialist
they want to now abolish
immigration customs and enforcement
because that was a big part of her
platform look at how well she did so
again rather than challenging her flawed
thinking this is the Homeland Security's
major enforcement arm let's not forget
Democrats have decided to just dash
leftward and endorse her idea we believe
that we should protect families that
need our help and that is not what Isis
doing today and that's why I believe you
should get rid of it start over
reimagine it and build something that
actually works look at ice what a group
of incompetence at this point they're
focused more on toddlers than terrorists
and instead of focusing on stopping bad
roads from coming in and stopping dirty
drug money from going out they're
focusing on separating kids from their
families hey dick the policy doesn't
exist any longer in any way ice does not
separate kids at the border like many of
the protesters surrounding Durbin
itseems like you know they all confuse
ice with Customs and Border Protection
its border control border patrol that
arrests illegals at the border and runs
them through processing ice is the law
enforcement agency that was set up you
remember after 9/11 to protect us from
international security threats
particularly those posed by people in
the country illegally
so how ironic is it that for New York
politicians senator Gillibrand
mayor de Blasio gubernatorial candidates
Cynthia Nixon and congressional
candidate Ocasio Cortes are now leading
the abolish ice movement charge nifty
well the problem for all of them is that
the people just aren't buying this the
latest Harvard Harris poll shows that
while 88 percent believe that families
who cross the border illegally should
not be separated 76 percent want secure
borders then 53 percent believe we
should prosecute those entering the
country illegally
while 64% sent agree that you should
send the border crossers back home but
no matter where they stand on the
nuances of immigration policy a whopping
70
% want stricter enforcement of existing
immigration laws so how you gonna do
that exactly if you abolish the agency
that's charged with investigating human
trafficking drug and weapons drug
smuggling weapons smuggling Isis the
agency that also tracks down criminal
illegal immigrants and then they remove
them from the country Democrats claim
that they're for that so
if criminals make it over the border are
we just to let them are all across the
country good look I'm turning that into
a into a plot platform that actually
wins votes you get rid of ice you're
gonna have a country that you're gonna
be afraid to walk out of your house I
love that issue of they're gonna
actually do that they're seriously
talking about that because they you are
gonna have a country that's crime ridden
the Border Patrol the Border Patrol
agents
ice these people are incredible well the
president understands the political
calculus here and his zero tolerance
policy remember it brought border
arrests in June down to their lowest
level since February according to the AP
that was the story but if Democrats
think melting down a national law
enforcement agency with 20,000 employees
that's working to keep Americans safe
and communities all across the u.s. is a
solution well I think they have another
thing coming
it not only sounds like an idea that
you'd hear at some undergrad Student
Center over some like Ben & Jerry's it's
also dead dangerous the Democrats push
to abolish ice and it's a it's as
off-key as the entertainment of some of
their big rallies over the weekend I'm
just gonna sing a lullaby that I wrote
and this is for those parents and we're
not gonna stop until they can sing them
to their kids again we treat asylum
seekers with compassion
we don't seek to punish them for trying
to do what's right for their families oh
you outshine the Morning Sun my son when
you smile I fall apart
side note it wasn't nominated but he
lost the atonement Tony for Best Musical
before Prince Best Actor he was
nominated no come on Hamilton was
fantastic
there's the writing the composing Trump
scores who wouldn't have to win on the
economy international relations trade
and now the second Supreme Court pick
dispirited Democrats are looking for
hope somewhere so what did they do this
weekend other than listening to some
off-key performances they turned to the
one the community organizer and chief
himself Barack Obama appeared with all
the little people at a Beverly Hills
fundraiser this weekend making his first
appearance in months he declared the
gathering a mope free zone and while the
word is that he's been devoting himself
to fundraising for his library and
writing his memoirs Obama is now on a
DNC fundraising swing commanding more
than a hundred thousand dollars a plate
and without mentioning Trump he told the
swanky crowd this is a moment of great
urgency and you're right to be concerned
then with the self-referential ere he
mused we shouldn't expect politics to be
entertaining all the time and Christina
Aguilera was wonderful but you don't
need to have an amazing singer at every
event sometimes you're just in a church
basement making phone calls and eating
cold pizza that's easy for him to say he
spent a lot of the last year between
like Tahiti and Richard Branson's
private island in the Caribbean cult
pizza though for the other people well
in many ways the explosion of protests
that tilt to the left the ineffective
Democratic leadership all of this is the
fulfillment of what Obama first assured
into his party the Obama era and the
party it left behind always prized style
over experience and results and
a new generation of inexperienced
charismatic leftists are moving to the
fore of the party they're giving
speeches they're leading marches and the
resisting Trump but original thinking
and a governing strategy continues to
elude them with every tack to the left
they merely estranged themselves from
the vast middle and working class of
this country catering only to the
progressive elites in Manhattan and
Malibu should this continue come
November well voters even Democratic
ones may be pulling the lever to abolish
the Democrats and that's the angle